what do you do when you're a 22 year old
billionaire stuck in quarantine with
your bestie during a global pandemic you
know what that means
tonight so killin you get glam drink
tequila
chow down on Hawaiian rolls and hang
with your ex
hmm well at least that's what Kylie
Jenner's doing on Wednesday the Keeping
Up with the Kardashians star got in full
glam to lounge around her brand new 36
point five million dollar la mansion
with her BFF Stassi yep that's Kylie
rocking a slick tight ponytail a face
full of makeup and a sheer full body
stocking apparently when you're Kylie
and you're bored in the house and you're
in the house bored it looks like this
Hey
whoa they'll expire though she even put
on heels quote for no reason at all okay
so all that glam in quarantine not so
relatable but we respect the hell out of
her commitment to glam so on brand but
then Kylie zoomed in on Stassi napping
and that that my friends is so relatable
[Music]
sleep eat drink repeat people and that's
just what they did except this isn't my
usual
slider buns usually I get the I won the
Foods good
you dance something isn't the same oh
but the night was just getting started
Stassi danced with Kylie's daughter
swore me to her favorite plague trolls
[Music]
then Kylie and her quarantine Powell did
what we all did when Beyonce dropped her
savage remix they danced again
[Music]
they toast it to their friendship to our
friendship
how many years now
[Music]
took a very important poll let's do you
guys like stresses hair rhymes or brown
call me down below and the drinks kept
flowing which may or may not have led to
my favorite moment of the night when
Stasi scared the living bejesus out of
Kylie let's run that back one more time
[Music]
the two danced with their roles again
because why not but before she got off
the internet she tik talked with her BFF
[Music]
and don't blink or you might miss a very
quick cameo by her ex Travis Scott the
rapper turned 28 on Thursday and Kylie
celebrated his big day posting this pic
to her insta story writing happy
birthday Travis Scott Stormies parents
the Kylie cosmetics founder also shared
a ton of pics on insta writing in part
quote I'm slowly but surely starting to
accept the fact that stormy is a daddy's
girl
kyliyah Travis have been spending a lot
of time together with stormy during
quarantine I want to say hi and bye yeah
all right
hello say bye okay
stormy crashed her dad's insta live
recently I have bought her every single
outdoor toy you could imagine she has
bouncy houses out there water toys she's
been in the pool every day I'm just
going to make better a little slip and
flood
I got us up inside and Kylie shared all
the stuff they're doing for fun during
her own insta live games a bouncy house
slip and slide the kid version of lit
from trying to keep her entertained a
baby and like didn't realize what's
happened there's no idea what's going on
know everything when et caught up with
Kylie's dad Caitlyn Jenner in March she
said that Kylie's totally thriving
during quarantine I think Kylie's happy
because she's at home and spending a lot
of time with stormy and she loves that
[Music]